Dear Fellow Scholars, this is Two Minute Papers
with Dr. Károly Zsolnai-Fehér.
Today we are going to perform pose estimation,
with an amazing twist.
You’ll love it!
But wait, what is pose estimation?
Well, simple, a video of people goes in, and
the posture they are taking comes out.
Now, you see here that previous techniques
can already do this quite well, even for videos.
So, by today, the game has evolved.
Just pose estimation is not that new, we need
pose estimation plus something else.
We need a little extra, if you will.
So, what can that little extra be?
Let’s look at three examples.
For instance, one, NVIDIA has an highly advanced
pose estimation technique that can refine
its estimations by putting these humans into
a virtual physics simulation.
Without that, this kind of foot sliding often
happens, but after the physics simulation,
not anymore.
As a result, it can understand even this explosive
sprinting motion.
This dynamic tennis serve.
You name it.
All of them are very close.
So, what is this good for?
Well, many things, but here is my favorite
- if we can track the motion well, we can
put it onto a virtual character, so we ourselves
can move around in a beautiful, imagined world.
So, that was one.
Pose estimation + something extra, where the
something extra is a physics simulation.
Nice.
Now, two, if we allow an AI to read the wifi-signals
bouncing around in a room, it can perform
pose estimation, even through walls.
Kind of.
Once again, pose estimation with something
extra.
And three, this is pose estimation with inertial
sensors.
This works when playing a friendly game of
table tennis with a friend…or…wait.
Or maybe, a not so friendly game of table
tennis.
And this works really well even in the dark.
So, all of these are pose estimation plus
something extra.
And now, let’s have a look at this new paper,
which performs pose estimation, plus…well,
pose estimation as it seems.
Okay, I don’t see anything nothing new here,
really.
Why is this work on Two Minute Papers?
Well, now hold on to your papers, and check
this out.
Yes!
Oh yes!
So what is this?
Well, here is the twist.
We can give a piece of video to this AI, write
a piece of text as you see up here, and it
will not only find what we are looking for
in the video, mark it, and then, even track
it over time.
Now that is really cool.
We just say what we want to be tracked over
the video, and it will do it automatically.
It can find the dog and the capybara.
These are rather rudimentary descriptions,
but it is by no means limited to that.
Look, we can also say a man wearing a white
shirt and blue shorts riding a surfboard.
And, yes!
It can find it.
And, also we can add a description of the
surfboard, and it can tell which is which.
And I like the tracking too.
This scene has tons of high-frequency changes,
lots of occlusion, and it is still doing really
well.
Loving it.
So, I am thinking that this helps us take
full advantage of the text descriptions.
Look.
We can ask it to mark the parrot and the cockatoo,
and it knows which is which.
So I can imagine more advanced applications
where we need to find the appropriate kind
of animal or object among many others, and
we don’t even need to know what to look
for.
Just say what you want, and it will find it!
I also liked how this is done with a transformer
neural network that can jointly process the
text and video in one elegant solution.
That is really cool.
Now, of course, every single one of you Fellow
Scholars can see that this is not perfect.
Not even close.
Depending on the input, temporal coherence
issues can arise, these are the jumpy artifacts
from frame to frame.
But, still, this is swift progress in machine
learning research.
We could only do this in 2018 and were very
happy about it, and just a couple papers down
the line, and now, we just say what we want
and the AI will do it.
And just imagine what we will have a couple
more papers down the line.
I cannot wait.
So, what would you use this for?
Please let me know in the comments below!
And wait, the source code, an interactive
demo, and a notebook are available in the
video description.
So, you know what to do.
Yes, let the experiments begin!
Thanks for watching and for your generous
support, and I'll see you next time!